yeah welcome to this blitz video play
one inform against Abe or other from
Switzerland at least that's the Swiss
flag and we've got a con variation going
to see Sonja White has got them mostly
this set up now and the question is how
to continue can play with the c-4 I can
play with f4 I like to go with a forward
I want to prevent b5 first so f or no
so the idea is to maybe I'm attack him
quickly here with sometimes you can even
play and very early f5f5f5 96 but it's
probably not one of those positions okay
probably need to put the note here
anyway so play Knight c3 sometimes 92 to
see force also also something to
consider interesting but now f5f5f5 96
sir take stakes and if you move the
night that f6 hanging okay let's try
this getting something going quickly
here of course after take stakes it's um
he can simply return a piece but at
least it opened up to the position so on
what now does he threaten well okay I
think I should take first this is also
with the tempo and now the question is
how to continue he cannot Castle short
if I play Bishop c4 that this is why
I'll be doing that this looks very
dangerous now for black I can continue
Bishop g5 root d 1 and so on this is a
monster piece really how does he get the
King out of the middle
cannot the castle long
this looks looks really dangerous yeah
maybe first first this year one thing to
consider here I really exchange sex huh
but it wouldn't tell them helping much
really if I may play Bishop b3 my
technique exchange um yeah I could take
on play Bishop to g5 this leads to a
very one-sided position but damn maybe
there are better ways to play I can even
just take a six come on let's take here
and then take a six this is a really
simple and and good I win a pawn and the
light squared Bishop will be exchanged
yeah okay let's let's windows tempe he
must react all the time and then I take
a six winning a porn in the process and
getting the light squared Bishop sixth
angel that I will probably be able to
play 95 and this is this typical
unopposed tonight on d5 leading to a
great position okay let's grab it here
yeah there are no exchange sacrifices
here simply because he's got no no
pieces left to to justify it with
anything yeah this was just just to
crush here based on 96 and I think that
black ass trillion in big trouble here
but some this g6 really am invited this
he needs to do something else if you
look at this yeah maybe he can take on
f5 first and then yeah this is probably
probably ok but some GF efe five but
this now is a disaster exactly because
of the game continuation now he will
never get get to safety with the skin
yeah typical motif to remember this 96
yeah thanks for watching